bonjour philippe bélair merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
quatre jours de manifestations où en est
la mobilisation aujourd'hui va y avoir
une cinquième journée d'action avoir
annoncé des renforts de police hier
oui ça c'est un petit peu accéléré
pendant la nuit
dans la mesure où depuis du jeu aux
particuliers aux
nationales notamment le ils disent que
le la simply mais aussi un sénateur de
guadeloupe
[Musique]
liste et qui à mon avis en cours ont
fermé ont jeté de l'huile sur le feu
mais par leurs déclarations
alors
ça veut dire qu'il ya une cinquième
journée de manifestation qui est prévu
les blocages vont continuer l'accès au
siège suit va être encore difficile
ne regardez pas seulement l'image du chu
aussi a chuté pas bloqué comme on le
prétend ci est toute l'île qui est
bloqué le chu vous voyez vous une image
puis dans ces images là c'est l'accès
est possible c'est toute l'île qui est
bloqué a pas un point de ville qui n'est
pas bloquée et particulièrement cette
nuit il y a eu véritablement
avant vous en avez une soignante 1 qui
disait que les conditions étaient
difficiles
est-ce que vous avez conscience que vous
mettez quand même en difficulté les
soignants
et goûter qui a dit combien en
difficulté du soignant et qui met des
milliers le soignant dans la rue je
regardais votre reportage sur le regain
de l'épidémie en europe ça ne vient ça
ne vient pas à l'esprit des gens que
c'est exactement ce que nous disons
c'est à dire que le choix qui a été fait
en termes de vaccination n'est pas le
bon nous ce qu'on ne revendique c'est
simplement qu'on arrête cette gestion
qui pour nous et des folles qui
cherchent du revient très cher et qui
n'a pas deux autres résultats
c'est ça pour le monde c'est la seule
solution
dès ce matin dans les colonnes de la
voix du nord qu'il n'y a pas de
confinement pour les non vaccinés de
prévus parce que le poste sanitaire a
été mis en place contrairement à
d'autres pays européens et il avait dit
qu'il n'y aurait pas de vaccination
obligatoire il avait dit qu'il n'était
pas question que il y a à nouveau le
reconduire il y avait plein de chose et
son contraire nous n'y voyons pas une
pension franchement que là il faut
changer de boîte qu'il faut changer son
fusil d'épaulé il faut impérativement
qu'il y ait une véritable gestion
sanitaire et non une gestion aciéristes
comme c'est le cas depuis deux ans où on
nous fait tourner en rond et autour du
virus on utilise de les russes à
d'autres fins puisque il y en même temps
lla sociale qui me des contres les
salariés et les agendas
les choix niant jeu voilà je vous le
rappelle l'an dernier et tout au fond
seuls des armes et sans protection donc
pour nous les arguments comptiez entre
nous ne tiennent pas ce sont des
arguments qui sont d'ailleurs
complètement hors sujet chacun nous
demandons
quelle issue possible alors jusqu'où
peuvent aller cc tension est ce que le
5e jour de tension va avoir jusqu'à
c'est envisageable ce que vous êtes dans
un état d'esprit jusqu'au boutiste ou
pas
alors ce qui change jusqu'au but ici ce
qui change qui ont la
leur nous faisons des propositions nous
avons déjà fait de
la politique que ce soit
nous avons tout fait et nous demandons à
ce que qu'on vienne s'asseoir autour
d'une table qu'on comprenne une chose
c'est que il y à 300-400 de la
population qui refuse
donc il faudrait qu on essaie de trouver
une solution ensemble nous nous estimons
qu'effectivement c'était un petit câlin
social ou même parfois j'en ai c'est
qu'il ya des regrets d'épidémie a
de manière continuelle ça veut dire
quelque chose n'est pas besoin d'être
c'est l'évidence c'est le bon sens mais
philippe besnard certains barrages
routiers ont été démontées par des
citoyens le medef de guadeloupe appelle
à débloquer les routes pour que
l'économie puisse continuer et des
patients disent ne pas pouvoir se faire
soigner notamment pour des
chimiothérapies est ce que vous ne
craignez pas de mettre une partie de la
population à dos
ce genre de situation on la reconnaît
rappelez vous il ya eu 2009
il n'en avons pas eu la population à dos
puisque figurez vous que ce qui montre
les barrages ils savent très bien opéré
les personnes qui sont dans le besoin
les personnes les ambulances et les
urgences etc c'est donc ce genre de
situation si je ne sais pas où nous sort
l'information que nous avons l'habitude
de jouer
merci philippe bélair d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général de la cgtg santé
guadeloupe